first on the subject of president
zielenski's speech
it was extremely sobering i was in kiev
earlier this week and i
saw for myself
the impact
the security threat is having on ukraine
and on stability in ukraine
and my view is this is one of the most
dangerous moments for european security
that we've experienced since early in
the 20th century and we need to show
unprecedented unity
there are many people who would want to
think hopefully about the situation but
i think we need to prepare for the worst
case scenario and that worst case
scenario could happen as early as next
week
the reality is that russia
does want to turn the clock back
they want to turn the clock back to the
1990s and before
and we've already seen a pattern of
behavior
we've seen russia invade two sovereign
nations and in the last week alone we've
seen a doubling of disinformation and
we've seen false flag operations in the
donbass region
i'm afraid that russia has shown
that they are not serious about
diplomacy
they've refused to engage
in talks at the osce
and we need to be strong
because that is the only thing that
russia understands
and i think we need to be strong in
supporting ukraine
and not selling ukraine out with
concessions on sovereignty
ukraine needs our support at the united
nations
and at the osce
and they also need our economic support
because there is a real threat of
economic destabilization
they need our defence support and the uk
is committed to continuing to supply
that support
standing shoulder to shoulder with
ukraine
and i heard president zielenski talk
about sanctions
we are resolute in imposing severe costs
on russia in the event of an invasion
including tough sanctions
we will stop oligarchs being able to
move their money internationally we will
stop them traveling and we will make it
tougher for russian companies to tap
into our capital markets and we're also
going to make it harder for russia to
access sovereign debt markets
you ask me about europe
we are working very closely with the
european union we're working very
closely with the united states we've
just had a meeting of the g7 foreign
ministers we are all completely united
in support of ukrainian sovereignty and
self-determination and this is not just
an issue
for europe
this is an issue for the world because
if a
sovereign nation
is able to be invaded with no
consequences
that sends a signal to other aggressors
around the world that is why our
partners whether it's australia or japan
around the world
are also supporting
ukraine
and supporting us in the
the steps we're taking and you asked me
about our relationship with europe and
i'm in i'm in the fortunate position
of negotiating the northern ireland
protocol as well as uh leading our work
on support for ukraine
we want a positive relationship with the
eu
we left the eu but we didn't leave
europe and we care deeply about european
security
we have a very positive trading
relationship with the eu
there are issues with an all-around
protocol we need to maintain police and
we need to maintain peace and political
stability in northern ireland but i've
had very positive conversations with
mauro safkovic i'm seeing him again this
monday and i believe we can find a way
forward because there is a massive
difference between the united kingdom
and our friends and allies across the
european union who are freedom-loving
democracies and the regime that is in
place in russia and i think what this
crisis has demonstrated
is we are united
we are prepared to put tough sanctions
in place in the event of an incursion we
are prepared to supply
that defensive support to ukraine and we
are prepared to stand up and be counted
and that's what our prime minister boris
johnson's speech
uh today it wasn't a surprise to me he
was coming but maybe it was a
a surprise to you but this is why the uk
has sent
a large delegation to the munich
security conference we care deeply about
this we want to work with our partners
across europe across the atlantic and
around the world to defend
peace and to defend democracy and
freedom